the jurgen experience there's got to be
something done to push back against this
this i this idea that we have right now
with
weaponized this idea of defunding the
police that the police are evil
you know that the police having money is
the problem yeah it's
it's crazy like there's a reason why we
have the police folks
they're necessary it's very important
and to
abandon them or to treat them like
anything other than members of our
community
and very important members of our
community is so short-sighted and so
crazy
and done by people that i don't think
understand psychology they don't i don't
think they understand violence
i don't think they understand crime and
it's again it's
it's weaponized it's this thing that
they're using now to push a political
agenda to
to align themselves with people you know
so that it
it helps them get reelected it helps
them gain power with their constituents
it's so dangerous and it's such a weird
thing to hear
coming out of mainstream politicians
mouths that we need to defund the police
like you guys are crazy
yeah i mean when people talk about
defunding along the lines of
take some of that money and put it into
communities like
that piece of it could be
if done well beneficial but why take it
from the cops i don't know that needs to
necessarily take from the comps but to
take
to really pay more attention to our
communities and what they're needing
you know the police over the last five
decades
have had to take on more and more and
more jobs
within the community um i mean a lot of
people would say that the the key
change came in like the 60s when
de-institutionalization happened from
the mental hospital so it used to be if
someone was mentally ill they went to
the hospital they basically stayed there
right
60s came de-institutionalization all
those folks
let's put them out in the community so
they can return to their homes
it was a lot of it during the reagan
right let's put money into community
mental health
that didn't happen the way it was
supposed to so the the community mental
health never got funded properly
and then all those folks who had mental
illness did not get proper treatment
went off meds all sorts of problems
rises and now
who has to deal with it police officers
right
so they became mental health clinicians
social workers
domestic violence you know all that
stuff so right if defunding the police
means
putting money into social services and
helping these
folks in a way that makes it so that the
police officers don't have to do those
jobs anymore
i'm all right with that and i think most
of the cops are because
i've spent half my career on this side
of police psychology stuff
training folks how to talk to people
with mental illness so they don't end up
shooting them
right i think there certainly should be
cops that are
designated to deal with those specific
type of situations people have found
amazing ways around it to work on it
we've developed what we call crisis
intervention teams
you know this came out of the 80s in
memphis that you know this cit thing
where
we have cops and clinicians that go out
together
but i don't know any clinician that
wants to do that by themselves so if you
defund the police and everyone says yeah
you know if it's a domestic violence
call
send a therapist out jesus christ well
i know because i work with cops that
domestic violence calls are one of the
most likely to end
in violence yes i'm not going there
right and i might
go there if there's an armed person with
me and i'll try to
you know to do but like as a team but
you're going to send me into a
potentially violent dangerous situation
where you've got
two people it's a utopian perspective on
a very complicated problem
yeah exactly it's a simple well we don't
like what we have so let's get rid of it
and that's it's far too simplistic well
and you've got the evidence right now i
mean this is a short term study
in new york city yeah you know and i
mean
minneapolis as well yep folks that i
know in new york
some of that training program i talked
about earlier the cops that worked on
that who decided you know what
retirement is the right thing for me
right now
yeah and who've left the force because
they just were like i can't do this this
is
the lack of support and and what's going
on is just too much it's not worth
staying anymore
and it's so dangerous yeah it's it's
very unsettling
and overwhelming and and to see how
rather than you know trying to come in
and figure out how to improve what we've
got it's like
it just doesn't make sense to throw our
hands up and say okay get rid of it
because
what's the plan b
you